- And before I could think
anymore,
the moose was like, Who's this
freaky, big-eared,
chinless, freak standing on my
grassy knoll?
And he charged right at me.
Charged me!
[dark electronic music]
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm Roy Wood Jr.
When traveling, make sure--
- [gasps]
- [screams]
[ominous music]
[maniacal laughter]
♪ ♪
- [growling]
[Roy shouts]
[cheers and applause]
- You know him from
his podcast,
the Harland Highway.
This is Harland Williams.
[cheers and applause]
- Well, I shouldn't even be
here, gang.
I shouldn't even be alive.
Yours truly has had a few
pretty dangerous encounters
with wildlife.
Uh, well, if you want to laugh
that I'm almost dead, uh...
But I had three encounters.
Three encounters with nature.
Way back in the day, I used
to be a forest ranger,
and I'm up in Northern Canada.
And I'm driving around
in my pickup truck.
I got a 3/4 ton pickup truck,
a'ight?
And I'm driving around, I'm
going down an old lumber road,
an old dirt lumber road.
And I'm just driving along,
having thoughts in my head
about, you know,
oatmeal and psoriasis
and things like that.
And I'm driving along,
and all of a sudden,
I see this big mound of grass,
and I slam on the brakes.
[mimics brakes screeching]
But it wasn't like a screeching
tire sound,
'cause I was on gravel.
I just told you that, gang.
[laughter]
It was more like a--
[mimics skidding on gravel]
So I stopped my 3/4 ton pickup
truck.
Hey.
And I look on the top
of this grassy knoll,
and there's a full-grown moose.
There's a moose standing
on a grassy knoll,
and I'm thinking, okay,
there's a moose, here's me;
I'm gonna see how close I can
get to the moose, right?
So he's pulling the grass.
He's like...
[imitates ripping]
And then he's chewing.
He's like...
[chomping]
You know, it's like watching
a fat family from Ohio
go through a lasagna bar
at Golden Corral, right?
And I'm thinking, if I imitate
these sounds,
I'll get close to the moose.
So I start pulling the grass
and I pull, chew.
[chomping]
And I keep getting closer
and closer and closer.
And then I'm about 20 feet
from this full-grown moose,
and I'm thinking,
wait a minute,
what's my end game here?
Do you want to get up to
this moose and scratch it
behind the ears?
Do I want to rub its hump?
Do I want to play with that
hairy nut bag
that dangles under its chin
and, you know, just fiddle
with its throat bag?
And before I could think
anymore,
the moose was like, Who's this
freaky, big-eared,
chinless, freak standing on my
grassy knoll?
And he charged right at me.
Charged me!
And at the last second, just
before he's about to hit me,
there was a dead tree hanging
over the grassy knoll.
He hit it, the tree shattered,
and he got spooked
and went the other way.
Now the upside is,
I peed my pants.
I watered the grass,
so there you go.
Now let's smash-cut
to Rwanda.
Hello.
We're looking for the legendary
mountain gorillas.
You know the ones that Dian
Fossey saw in the mist?
But it was really like her bong
smoke, like--
And we're climbing up this
volcano and boom,
we come across
the mountain gorilla.
The mother and the children and
the aunties.
But where's the big boy, huh?
They told me there was a
500-pound silverback gorilla
up there on the mountain,
right?
I'm like, "Where's the big
boy?"
And all of a sudden, we hear
it.
It's like--
[loud screeching]
I'm like, "What the fuck?"
There he is.
500-pound silverback
opens the bamboo, right?
Just peels it open, presents
himself, postures, right?
Slides down right in front of--
and just standing there
with his big fuckin' eyebrows.
[loud screeching]
Just staring at all of us.
And I'm thinking,
"This is great."
Till I realized in our group of
eight people,
I'm the only guy with a
brand-new,
bright, shiny red
baseball hat.
[laughter]
And so now, two Spanish words
are going through my head.
Olé! Olé!
And sure enough, just
as I finished that thought,
I heard our guide go,
"He's attacking!"
Here comes this giant 500-pound
silverback gorilla,
just charging at me.
He's beating his chest.
He's like--
[loud screeching]
He just hitting
his areolae so hard
I thought they're gonna fly off
and land on my eyes, right?
Here he comes.
But these mountain gorillas,
they do a thing
called a mock charge.
It's to show dominance.
So he wasn't really gonna hit
me,
but he came
closer to the moose.
He came, like, four feet in
front of me
and then went the other way.
And of course, at that point,
I once again produced
something in my pants.
It was a--
it was a Cracker Barrel
meatloaf.
Uh...
And lastly, let's smash-cut
to the Pacific Ocean.
Sir, if you could look away,
sir; your focus is scary.
Uh...
I'm fishing the Pacific Ocean,
gang.
Going for salmon.
Oh, you ever catch a salmon,
my love, huh?
When you're not busy rolling
around in the hazelnut fields?
I'm fishing.
I'm out in a 17-foot boat
fishing for salmon, right?
I got a bait boy with me.
This guy's like a college kid.
He's like Spicoli from "Fast
Times at Ridgemont High."
Just a stoner dude.
I'm pretty sure when I wasn't
looking,
he was smoking the bait, right?
And we're out there fishing,
and the ocean's nice and calm,
and I look about 50 yards away,
and all of a sudden
I see this circle of bubbles
on the surface of the water.
Big circle of bubbles.
And what the hell is that?
And then all of a sudden,
two giant humpback whales
just exploded
from under the water.
Their mouths open;
they swallowed a whole
school of fish.
And I was like, What the hell
was that, stoner bro?
And he was like,
Oh, fuck, man.
He's like, The humpback whales,
that's how they hunt, man.
They go down to the bottom
of the ocean,
they look for a school of fish,
and then they blow bubbles out
of the asshole on their head.
Right?
So they swim around the school
of fish
and they create
a wall of bubbles
and then they come up
and they swallow
the whole school of fish.
The fish in the wall of bubbles
are afraid to go through
so they get trapped, right?
And I'm thinking,
wouldn't that be funny
if I could get those whales
to come over here
and I get a nice little picture
of the whales.
So of course I start doing some
whale calls to attract them.
Right? I'm like...
[high-pitched squeal]
[imitates whale barking]
[mimics high-pitched whining]
Nothing.
So I go back to fishing,
and a few minutes later,
holy fuck.
I look beside me,
a bubble comes up.
Right beside the boat.
Just one bubble, right?
There's probably, like,
a sea cucumber fart
coming up from the--
So I'm like, there's a bubble.
And then suddenly there's
another bubble
and another one and another one
and all of a sudden I realize,
holy fuck, eh?
They're doing a bubble circle
right under the damn boat.
And I'm like, "What the"--
And all of a sudden I put
the boat in reverse,
I pull that sucker backwards,
and I swear to God, just as
I get out of the bubble circle,
three feet off the front
of the boat,
two giant humpback whales--
these things are 60-feet long,
the length of three
Greyhound buses--
mouths open, tons of fish
going down,
and I'm like, holy shit,
that could have been us.
And the stoner dude was like,
Yeah.
[cheers and applause]
God bless ya.
Thank you very much.
- Harland Williams, everybody.